today i want to talk about who the
tarnished is
who our player character in eldon ring
is going to be
from the trailer and some interviews
with miyazaki we can begin to paint a
picture of who we'll play as when we
begin the game
it's kind of a mix in that it's still
open to role-playing
because the details are left out but
there are some kinds of motivations
and contexts that are going to be
informing who the tarnished is and who
we're playing as regardless of what kind
of specific backstory we give them
and i think the best way to do this is
to first create a timeline
of what has led up to the game because
that will be like the overarching
backstory or context
in a way of who our tarnished is and who
they're coming to the lands between
as so at first the lands between
were in a essentially pretty paradise
eden state they were blessed by the
elden ring which was visually
represented by the erd tree
and the golden light that was filling
everywhere and everyone
all had a golden light or aura shown in
their eyes
in the trailer we see something that i
would interpret as this aura
as the kind of golden light and color
that we see emanate from
our ring our gauntlet and also from some
of the enemies as their summoning
weapons
this gold aura is a blessing or grace
of the urgery which is probably by way
of the elden ring
because the earth tree is kind of just
the conduit or representation of the
ring
and after some amount of time the lands
between
some lost this grace and their golden
eyes
so just some subsection of the people
there these people who lost their grace
and golden eyes
were the tarnished and it should be
noted that pure gold doesn't tarnish
so maybe these were beings that for some
reason were different from everyone else
even before they lost this grace maybe
there's some reason they lost this grace
that allows them to be tarnished they
weren't pure
and these people the tarnished were
banished exiled and sent out
of the lands between they were cast out
of paradise in a biblical sort of way
now all of this occurred a long time
before the game the people that were
exiled were tarnished but they're not
tarnished we play outs
these were the ancestors of the player
character and some others that we were
going to find in the game
so who we play as our ancestors were
banished from the lands between
and have lived in exile for a long time
probably going through many generations
because it seems very much like the
player character was not originally in
the lands between so they were never
there their people
were once the tarnished as a people
group
but this specific tarnish we play as has
never been to the lands between
so it's coming home it's coming back to
where they were but it's also a new
place
and at least some of those who were in
the lands between and weren't exiled
looked and currently looked down upon
the tarnished and we see this in the
tone that the many armed prince
character talks about us the tarnished
pretending as a lord
a lowly
playing as a tarnished so then a long
time
after the exodus the elden ring is
shattered which we see
happening in the teaser shattered
by someone or something
again this is still before the game
starts the shattering led to a war
and the abandonment of the greater will
which we still don't have super clear
ideas
on what the greater will is it's
definitely something related to the
elden ring
maybe it's something that gave the elden
ring its power or created the elden ring
it's pretty unsure the greater will is
one of the things we have the least
details on
and the shattering also led to a return
of the grace which was lost by the
exiled descendants
it calls out to them and beckons them to
return to the lands between
so this lost grace as we hear from the
first female voice in the gameplay
trailer
is beckoning the tarnish to return the
descendant of those originally exiled
and this is where the game begins with
the tarnish being called back by their
previously lost grace
and this grace is also seemingly
referred to
as the flame of ambition as that's like
the motivating factor
that is described in the gameplay
trailer towards the tarnish coming back
to the lands between
and here i think a direct quote from
miyazaki is important
but one of the main themes of the game
is how the player the tarnished
approaches or treats this newfound grace
and this return to the land that they
were once banished from
how they interpret this and its meaning
end quote
so is it redemption is it revenge how
does the tarnished react
to coming back to paradise finding it
ruined and being spurned by those who
fail
to protect the paradise the ring and
keep the peace
does the tarnished help or take power
for themselves
to me this reads as kind of leading to
multiple endings
in dark souls 3 we saw a couple
different endings somewhat like this
whether you relink the fire or you let
it go out
or you take power for yourself so it
seems like the tarnished has a similar
set of options they can
choose how they want to influence and
help or hurt
or ignore the world the lands between
that they have historically been spurned
from another thing that's kind of
interesting to me
is how the tarnish is going to be
dealing with this
newfound race as miyazaki puts it this
was a grace that was originally with the
tarnished
people but the tarnish themselves that
we play as
never had this grace so it's a
completely new phenomenon for them
another thing that i think is key to
point out is the use of the word
grace and the connotations behind it
when we talk about the tarnish coming
back to this broken land
and deciding what to do part of the
power that will allow them to do this
is this lost race and grace is something
that has strong
biblical and religious connotations
which is something we see
a lot in the trailer and the kind of
setup these kinds of
religious orders and belief systems
so grace could imply a charitable and or
benevolent
tone to the tarnished and to the power
they're having
so that could skew us towards helping or
restoring the land
and one last thing is that other
characters are beckoned back
too by this grace with their own
motivations the player character decides
how they want to move forward with all
this but the other characters which are
i guess other tarnished
have their own motivations and interests
as they return
to this land that they were also exiled
from one more note from the trailer is
that the female voice also says we have
an unending curse
under which we will continually die so
perhaps this
beckoning lost grace is also a curse or
contract that keeps the tarnished from
permanently dying
constantly restoring them and reviving
them and making them respawn
until they restore the elden ring and
become an elden lord
now this could be argued that it's just
a reason for the gameplay
but in past from soft games the whole
idea
of repeatedly dying and coming back to
life and going hollow
or not going hollow has been a very
strong theme in the game in both the
mechanics and
the story they've been very intertwined
some ludonarrative
aspects going on so i think it's safe to
say that this will be some significant
element in eldon ring
so that's our timeline we have a
relatively straightforward set
of events even if we don't have a lot of
detail on all of them
a takeaway for me is that it seems like
the tarnished is more directed than
previous souls born protagonists
and that's likely thanks to george rr
martin being
very influential in the creation of the
deep mythos the background
and the setting for the story and the
world of eldon ring
a lot of this backstory and setup
miyazaki describes as
george rr martin being a very big part
in creating that
and helping inform this as the initial
spurring moment
of the player character previous games
had this in some form
but it seems to have more of a narrative
weight behind it in this iteration in
elden ring
we have more explicit background about
the tarnished and what motivations could
influence them
and that's going to create probably a
more directed push from the tarnish to
enter this world
and take their place in it and even with
that said it's still very open-ended for
role-playing and
open-ended in terms of what the player
does with the motivations
because the player could still be from a
variety of lands outside of the
lands between and because they're a
descendant their life can be wholly
their own so role playing can still be
a completely vanilla wide open
paint as you wish blank canvas kind of
experience
but it's more directed in having
specific motivations
and a context heading into the world of
the lands between
so it's an interesting mix of open-ended
and more directed
but i think it's a good change of pace
while also keeping
important aspects that made people enjoy
the previous role-playing elements
and contextualizations and setups that
were enjoyed in the previous game
so that's my timeline and some
reflections on who the tarnished is
so they have more motivations they're
slightly more directed
they've been wronged in the past or
their people have been wronged in some
way
and now they return to the broken
paradise so they were once cast out of
exile to find it destroyed
and it'll be up to them what they want
to do inside this broken land
and what they want to do as they become
an elden lord whatever that means
and who they choose to brandish the
elden ring for
for themselves for the tarnished for
everyone in the land between for one
section of the lands between
for a new people a new world coming out
of the lands between
to get a better idea on any of that
we're going to need more information
and as it comes out i'll make more
videos hope you guys have enjoyed this
video if you have any ideas about who
the tarnished is
or about the world and setting we find
ourselves in as we enter the game
please feel free to leave in the
comments and yeah thank you for watching
i'll see you in the next video